Bonjour! Vous aimez manger?
-OUI!
-Seulement allongée.
-Bon, ça tombe très bien car aujourd'hui
on va parler d'alimentation médiévale.
Et attention, on gardera les grands festins
et autres banquets que vous avez sûrement
déjà en tête pour la fin, parce qu'ils
ne sont ni représentatifs de toute la période,
ni de tout le monde.
-Quand la prof parle de période, elle fait
référence au Haut Moyen-Âge, du Ve siècle
à l'an mil, au Moyen-Age central du XIe au
XIIIe siècle, et au bas Moyen-Age des XIV
et XVe siècles.
Eh ouais, l'épisode d'aujourd'hui sera chronologique!
-Et fantastique, évidemment.
On va s'intéresser à ce que les différents
groupes sociaux avaient dans leur assiette,
et pour ça on passera forcément par un peu
d'histoire de l'agriculture, et surtout par
toutes les pratiques sociales liées au repas.
-Être allongée.
-Ben non, justement.
T'es has been.
A partir du IVe siècle, des peuples qualifiés
de barbares arrivent en Europe occidentale
et sèment la zizanie parmi les habitudes
alimentaires des romains.
Par la suite, les habitants d'Europe occidentale
opèrent un mélange entre des héritages
antiques et barbares.
Comme on a peu de données archéologiques
pour cette période, on se base surtout sur
les sources écrites, donc on sait peu de
choses sur les paysans mais surtout sur la
noblesse et les clercs.
-Parmi l'élite romaine, nous avions une alimentation
très fine.
Nous préférions le pain, alors que les paysans
prenaient leurs céréales en bouillie.
Nous pouvions manger des légumes secs ou
verts, du fromage...
le vin était toujours coupé d'eau, et surtout
nous avions une sauce que nous mettions absolument
partout, le garum.
C'était...
tousse des entrailles de poisson fermentées.
-Erk.
Nous avons gardé le plus longtemps possible
l'habitude de banquetter sur des stibadium,
ces sortes de lits de table dont ceci n'est
qu'une pâle copie.
Nous avions deux repas, le prandium au milieu
de la matinée et la cena en fin d'après-midi.
Certains évêques du VIe siècle maintenaient
encore ces pratiques, mais les bonnes choses
se sont vite perdues...
-Effectivement, l'arrivée de peuples barbares
amène bon nombre de pratiques qui choquent
les romains.
Attention, ces peuples n'avaient rien de sauvage
sanguinaires.
Enfin, presque.
Ils pratiquaient l'agriculture depuis bien
longtemps, et savaient très bien se tenir
mais n'avaient juste pas le même style.
Par exemple, ils buvaient surtout de la bière
ou cervoise, et ça choquait pas mal les ecclésiastiques
qui préféraient le vin.
Pour eux, la bière, c'était la boisson des
adorateurs du dieu Woden, Odin pour les intimes,
donc un truc de païens.
-Ils consommaient leur viande grillée, soit
disant qu'elle leur procurait force et violence,
et goûtaient très peu nos plats de volaille
ou de poisson.
-De plus ils accompagnent leurs plats d'oignon,
d'ail et surtout de beurre, la honte ultime
pour les romains.
Ces pratiques font d'ailleurs l'objet d'une
lettre de Sidoine Apollinaire qui se plaint
de l'odeur de la cuisine des Burgondes qui
vivent chez lui, et dont j'avais déjà parlé
dans l'épisode sur lesdits Burgondes.
Chez les barbares, comme chez les romains,
le repas est un rituel très important, régi
par des codes dont on garde peu de traces
parce que ces peuples ont laissé peu de sources
écrites.
Dans plusieurs récits de banquets du Haut-Moyen-Âge,
le récit de beowulf par exemple, la reine
présente au roi une coupe d'hydromel en présence
de ses guerriers, ce qui lui permet de réaffirmer
son pouvoir.
-En anglais, le mot lord dérive de hlaford:
«le gardien du pain». Donc on suit le
mec qui détient les clés du garde-manger,
et qui boit en premier.
Par la suite les peuples d'Europe se christianisent,
ce qui a des conséquences sur les pratiques
alimentaires.
Un calendrier du jeûne se met en place, ainsi
que le péché de gourmandise qui vise principalement
les moines.
La règle de Saint-Benoît, par exemple, écrite
au milieu du VIe siècle, recommande les légumes
et le pain mais interdit la viande de quadrupèdes
et n'autorise que le vin de mauvaise qualité.
Elle interdit aussi la satiété, et l'ivresse.
-CHOUETTE.
-Les banquets de l'élite se plient aussi
aux règles de l’Église, qui interdit qu'ils
aient lieu dans des églises à partir de
561.
Ça laissait des miettes partout à la fin...
A partir de cette date, les princes construisent
donc des grandes halles en bois dédiées
aux banquets, dont le but est encore une fois
d'impressionner les invités.
Mais alors, que ripaillons-t-on en ce début
du Moyen-Âge, puisque l'héritage romain
commence à disparaître?
Les aliments qui apportent le plus de calories
sont les céréales et autres légumineuses.
En Europe, c'est le blé qui domine, clairement,
avec ses potes l'épeautre, l'avoine, le seigle,
etc.
Ailleurs on trouve le riz en Asie, le maïs
en Amérique centrale...
Bref, chacun sa spécialité.
On mange donc surtout du blé, en pain ou
en bouillie, et quand ce n'est plus la saison
on peut se rabattre sur des légumineuses
comme les pois ou les lentilles mais on n'aime
pas trop ça.
Tout le reste du repas est considéré comme
de l'accompagnement, qu'on appelle le companagium:
-Ce qui va avec le pain.
-Il peut s'agir de légumes du jardin, de
condiments, de produits cueillis en forêt
comme les champignons, ou encore de viande,
d’œufs et de produits laitiers.
Parmi les viandes consommées, on trouve les
poules, canards, oies, bœufs, moutons chèvres,
et porc.
-A part le porc ils ont tous une utilité
à côté, on a pas de place pour le gaspillage.
-Pour ce qui est des boissons, on n'aime pas
trop l'eau à cette époque.
On préfère le vin, LA boisson de l'époque,
mais on peut aussi se rabattre sur de la bière,
ou des boissons alcoolisées à base de miel,
de plantes...
-Le dénominateur commun, c'est l'alcool quoi.
-Ouais, tes ancêtres aimaient bien quand
ça montait au cerveau.
Durant la période carolingienne, on garde
ce triptyque de la sainte bouffe: céréales,
vin, et viande, en quantité variable selon
le statut des gens.
Dans certains documents, on trouve aussi mention
d'arbres fruitiers et de jardins où on trouve
à la fois des plantes médicinales, des condiments
et des légumes.
Mais tout ça, ça reste des à-côtés.
Les banquets se faisaient assis, et plus allongés.
On y trouvait le repas, la collatio, mais
aussi la potatio, la boisson prise en commun...
Au niveau de la nourriture, les récits de
ces banquets nous permettent de constater
qu'à la fin du Haut MA, on n'utilise plus
l'huile d'olive ni le garum hérités des
romains.
A la place, on voit apparaître de plus en
plus d'épices: le poivre, la cannelle,
le galanga, le clou de girofle, et surtout
la star incontestée du MA: le gingembre.
A partir du XIe siècle, le monde change.
Bon, on est toujours sur le triangle céréales-viande-vin,
mais les pécores ont de moins en moins de
viande.
Les surfaces cultivées augmentent, ils deviennent
donc de plus en plus dépendants des céréales
et connaissent des périodes de disette quand
y'en a plus.
-Le principal aliment pour beaucoup reste
donc le PAIN.
Et pour le préparer, les seigneurs ont la
bonne idée d'installer dans les villages
des moulins et des fours banaux.
A utiliser obligatoirement, et contre paiement
bien sûr.
Quels génies.
-Au début du XIe siècle, les seigneurs vivent
encore dans de petits châteaux, le plus souvent
construits en bois, qu'on appelle les châteaux
à motte.
Y'avait pas vraiment la place pour festoyer
là dedans, donc les halles servant au festin
étaient encore construites à part.
On les appelait les aula.
-Puis rapidement, ils deviennent des châteaux
forts dans lesquels se trouve la aula ainsi
que des salles plus privées dans lesquelles
le seigneur pouvait recevoir ses hôtes VIP
pour grailler en paix.
Il graille un peu de tout, puisque le champart
qu'il prélève à ses paysans lui permet
d'avoir du pain, du vin, et du bours...
Des produits laitiers.
Mais il déguste surtout de la viande.
Elle est constituée à plus de 90% de viande
d'élevage, le reste étant du gibier et de
la volaille.
Les seigneurs chassaient, mais c'était un
loisir et une manière de montrer aux autres
qui était le patron, donc ils n'avaient pas
besoin de la chasse pour se nourrir.
Du côté des moines, on consomme surtout
de la volaille mais certains religieux comme
Bernard de Clairvaux s'inquiètent des nouvelles
habitudes peu catholiques de ces derniers.
-A partir du XIIe siècle, certains moines
se mettent à se cuisiner des quadrupèdes
alors que c'était interdit, à verser des
épices dans leur vin pour qu'il ait meilleur
goût, et même à essayer d'assaisonner leurs
plats pour qu'ils soient meilleurs!
C'est la décadence.
-En ville, enfin, on trouve quelques jardins
et vergers mais la plupart des citadins sont
des flemmards et surtout n'ont pas de cuisine
chez eux, donc ils achètent leur pain déjà
cuit, leurs plats déjà cuisinés, ou vont
à la taverne.
-La vraie vie.
On avance encore dans le temps.
A partir du XIVe siècle, on connaît un peu
mieux l'alimentation grâce aux livres de
cuisine, aux différentes sources écrites,
à l'iconographie, l'archéologie, etc.
Et en fait, c'est un peu toujours la même
chose...
-Du pain, du vin, de la viande...
-Mais tout ça coûte cher, même pour les
seigneurs.
Guillaume de Murol, par exemple, un seigneur
auvergnat du XVe siècle, consacre 54% de
son budget en nourriture, alors que pour les
nobles de l'époque moderne le budget bouffe
ne représente que 5 à 20% de leurs dépenses.
-Et parmi ces aliments le pain reste le plus
important, puisqu'on peut en gruger entre
500gr et 2 kilos par jour.
-Par contre, tout le monde n'a pas droit à
du pain béni.
Chez les riches, on commence par becqueter
son pain blanc, un pain à base de froment
qui est considéré comme la «céréale
reine»
-C'est le pain du roi.
-Et du coup, forcément, on ne le trouve pas
pour une bouchée de pain.
-Ceux qui n'ont pas un gagne-pain suffisant
ne mangent pas de ce pain là.
Ils se contentent de pains d'orge, d'avoine...
De tout ce qui pousse chez eux, quoi, ils
gagnent leur pain à la sueur de leur front.
-Les nobles se retireraient vite ce pain là
de la bouche.
-Parfois, quand les récoltes sont mauvaises,
on fabrique même des pains de substitution
à partir de tout ce qu'on trouve, céréales,
légumineuses...
Même si ça fait des pains dégueulasses.
-De quoi vous faire passer le goût du pain.
-Pas de pain, pas de gain.
-Il arrive encore aussi qu'on savoure les
céréales en bouillie, ou bien en polenta
ou en pâtes en Italie.
Pour ce qui est de la consommation de viande
aussi on observe des différentes entre nobles
et pécores, mais pas que.
-A ce propos, saviez-vous qu'à mon époque
le mot «viande» désignait la nourriture
en général? Du coup, la viande, on l'appelait
la «chair».
-Bref.
Les nobles et les membres de communautés,
que ce soient des monastères, des écoles,
des hôpitaux...
Étaient ceux qui s'empiffraient le plus,
logiquement.
Mais il y a aussi de grosses différences
entre les villes, où on mange au moins 20kg
de viande par an, et les campagnes où ça
peut baisser à 2 kilos par an.
Ça s'explique par le fait qu'il y a plus
de boucheries en ville, c'est pourquoi on
a aussi plutôt tendance à y manger de la
viande fraîche alors que la viande dans les
campagnes est souvent séchée ou salée pour
conserver plus longtemps.
Dans les villes, il y a d'ailleurs une spécialisation
de plus en plus importante dans les métiers
de l'alimentation: on trouve des boulangers,
bouchers, charcutiers, taverniers...
Qui doivent obéir à des règles de métier
précises.
Par exemple, les bouchers ont interdiction
de vendre de la viande cuite, parce que c'est
la spécialité des charcutiers.
-D'ailleurs on ne faisait pas qu'acheter de
la nourriture chez ces artisans, mais on pouvait
aussi y faire cuire ses propres plats, puisque
comme on l'a dit plus tôt très peu d'urbains
avaient une cuisine ou une cheminée chez
eux.
-Après, même si on consommait de la viande,
de préférence très cuite, il y avait plus
de cent jours de jeûne dans l'année, o il
était interdit de manger de la viande.
Pendant le Carême, on interdit aussi les
œufs et les produits laitiers, et certains
comme les moines peuvent aussi respecter les
jeûnes du mercredi, du samedi, et de l'Avent.
Ça fait beaucoup de jours sans viande, où
on la remplace donc par du poisson.
Même les graisses animales sont remplacées,
par de l'huile d'olive ou du lait d'amendes.
On consomme surtout des poissons d'eau douce,
pour des soucis évidents d'approvisionnement.
Les poissons d'eau de mer peuvent être apportés
dans les grandes villes par des convois de
50 à 200 chevaux, on appelle cette organisation
«chasse-marée».
-On peut aussi les manger de conserve, ou
salés.
A partir du XIVe, par exemple, le hareng devient
super répandu parce qu'on peut le conserver
facilement jusque Carême.
-La graisse de baleine, quant à elle, n'est
jamais interdite car on considère la baleine
comme un poisson.
Au niveau des boissons, on fait pousser de
la vigne presque partout en Europe et on consomme
environ 1l de vin par repas, soit 2l par jour,
mais il dépasse rarement les 10° d'alcool.
Quand même.
-On aimait pas trop boire de l'eau.
Pas pour les microbes, on savait même pas
ce que c'était, mais parce qu'elle avait
aucun goût!
-Malheureusement, en certaines périodes de
disette le vin devient trop cher pour nos
simples pécores qui se rabattent sur le cidre
ou la bière, qu'on appelle encore cervoise
à l'époque.
Ou Ale, en Angleterre.
Plus il y a de brasseries dans une ville,
plus on comprend qu'il y a un problème d'approvisionnement
en vin.
Finalement la bière se popularise en Europe
du Nord, et l'utilisation du houblon dans
sa fabrication se généralise au cours du
XIVe siècle.
Ce qui se développe de plus en plus, enfin,
sont les épices.
Du XIVe au XVIe siècle, c'est l'apogée des
épices en Europe: on les fait venir grâce
aux commerçants vénitiens ou génois d'Inde,
de Chine ou d'Indonésie, parce qu'elles donnent
un bon goût au plat et viennent d'Orient,
donc touchent à l'imaginaire des européens
qui se font encore une idée légèrement
biaisée de l'Orient.
Y'a qu'à voir ma vidéo sur Marco Polo pour
m'en rendre compte, et pour donner un autre
exemple on pensait que la cannelle était
cueillie dans le nid du phénix, ce qui est
peu probable.
Le gingembre est l'épice la plus présente,
mais aussi la cannelle, le safran, le galanga,
la noix de muscade...
Et quelques épices européennes, quand même:
la moutarde, la sauge et l'ail.
-Au Moyen-Âge, on se moque un peu du goût
qu'a un aliment tout seul: ce qui intéresse
les cuistots, c'est le mélange de plein d'aliments,
avec des épices, pour créer de nouvelles
saveurs.
-Évidemment c'est dans la noblesse qu'on
en consomme le plus, mais à partir du XVe
siècle de nouvelles routes commerciales permettent
de faire un peu baisser les prix.
La boisson la plus représentative de ce goût
pour les épices est l'hypocras, un mélange
d'une petite dizaine d'épices, qu'on sert
plutôt en fin de repas avec des gaufres.
Tous les aliments cités jusqu'ici font l'objet
de livres de cuisine, qui apparaissent à
partir de la fin du XIIIe siècle, comme le
Viandier qui est très diffusé et propose
de nombreuses recettes.
On trouve aussi à partir du XVIe siècle
des manuels de «civilité» qui expliquent
comment bien se tenir à table.
Et on va terminer sur la table, justement,
en s'attaquant enfin aux banquets médiévaux.
Bon, déjà y'a pas de table, déso, vous
le saviez peut-être déjà mais il y avait
très peu de mobilier fixe dans les châteaux,
comme la cour était souvent itinérante.
De ce fait on pose des tréteaux, des planches
dessus, et voilà pour les tables.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne soigne pas ses
invités, on met de belles tentures sur les
murs, souvent aux couleurs des invités ou
de l'hôte, de la vaisselle d'or et d'argent
pour les invités les plus prestigieux...
Au sol, on répand une «jonchée» de
foin et de fleurs, et on pose différents
objets décoratifs et utiles sur la table.
Les objets réservés aux invités de marque
sont les «nefs»: ce sont de grands
plats en forme de navires dans lequel les
invités peuvent déposer leurs couverts,
leurs restes, etc.
-On met des nappes blanches, aussi.
Ça cache les tréteaux, et on peut s'essuyer
les mains dessus.
-Elles ne devaient pas rester blanches longtemps.
-Par contre on ne mettait pas le couvert,
comme aujourd'hui, on apportait le tout avec
les plats.
La nourriture était dans des écuelles s'il
y avait du liquide, ou posée sur une tranche
de pain appelée tranchoir, qui finissait
dans la gueule des chiens à la fin du repas.
Il y avait du vrai beau pain blanc destiné
à être mangé.
Il pouvait y avoir des couteaux et des cuiller,
mais pas de fourchettes avant le XVIe siècle,
et de toute façon on mangeait plutôt avec
les mains.
Les invités d'honneur occupaient la table
du haut bout, dos à la cheminée, par opposition
à celle du bas bout pour les invités les
moins prestigieux.
Avant de commencer à manger, on se lave les
mains, comme on va mettre ses mains dans le
plat ensuite.
-Commencez pas à vous emballer sur l'hygiène
de l'époque, se laver les mains, ça veut
surtout dire se lécher les doigts avant de
les mettre dans le plat.
Chacun ses valeurs.
-Pour ce qui est du repas, les banques sont
divisés en différents mets dans lesquels
on trouve des mélanges de plats chauds, froids,
sucrés, salés, poissons, viandes...
Il y a beaucoup de plats par banquet, mais
ils sont destinés à être répartis un peu
partout sur les tables donc les invités ne
mangent pas de tout.
Heureusement pour leur estomac.
On commence souvent par des potages, puis
le «rôt».
-Non, c'est le rôti.
Il peut aussi être composé de tourtes, pâtés,
etc.
Vers la fin du XVe siècle, alors que tout
au long du Moyen-Âge les aliments cuits ont
été largement valorisés, il arrive qu'on
serve des plats de salades aux invités prestigieux.
Vers la fin du repas, on sert de l'hypocras
avec des gaufres, puis enfin le dernier mets
dont j'adore le nom: le «boutehors»,
qui indique aux invités qu'il est bientôt
temps de dégager.
-Pratique pour abréger les repas de famille.
-Il est composé d'un digestif avec quelques
sucreries comme du gingembre confit.
Mais le banquet a surtout une fonction sociale,
et politique: on veut en mettre plein la
vue.
Ça passe par l'assiette, mais pas seulement:
il dure entre plusieurs heures et plusieurs
jours, comme lors des noces de Charles le
Téméraire où on festoie dix jours.
En plus les restes des banquets sont distribués
comme aumône, donc on peut même passer pour
généreux.
Le caractère grandiloquent de ces banquets
s'observe grâce aux entremets: ce sont
des petits spectacles, dans des décors de
carton peint ou d'aliments, montrés entre
deux plats.
Il peut aussi s'agir d'aliments mis en scène,
comme un cygne cuit puis à nouveau recouvert
de ses plumes.
Certains banquets du XVe siècle sont mémorables:
le banquet des noces de Charles le Téméraire,
déjà, durant lequel le duc commence par
manger seul le premier soir alors que tout
le monde fait la fête parce qu'il n'est pas
encore marié avec sa future épouse, donc
faudrait pas heurter les mœurs.
L'entremets de ce banquet était constitué
de deux chandeliers monumentaux munis de miroirs,
avec des rochers et des montagnes à leurs
pieds.
Il profite aussi de ce banquet pour offrir
un spectacle au peuple de Bruges ainsi que
tous les restes du festin.
En 1466, le pape Paul II organise un banquet,
mais lui ne fait pas les choses à moitié
non plus: il l'offre à toute la population
de Rome, c'est un goûter monumental servi
dans les jardins du palais San Marco.
Pour les pâtes servies à cette occasion
il a fallu acheter 8571 œufs, 3112 parmesans,
et il y avait plus de 900 invités.
J'ai dépensé sans compter
Enfin, l'un des banquets médiévaux les plus
célèbres est le banquet du faisan, organisé
à Lille par le duc de Bourgogne Philippe
le Bon en 1454.
Il a lieu à l'occasion de la visite des ducs
de Clèves et d'Alençon, et sert aussi aux
projets politiques du duc, puisqu'il se clôt
par la promesse des invités de partir en
croisade.
Bon, mais finalement, une fois la digestion
passée, chacun est rentré chez soi.
Mais c'était une sacré digestion: le banquet
dure plusieurs jours, avec des successions
de tournois et de repas, le plus important
ayant lieu le 17 février.
A l'entrée du banquet, on trouve un entremets
dans lequel une statue d'enfant tout nu pisse
de l'eau de rose.
-Appétissant.
-L'autre entremets célèbre met en scène
un faisan vivant, sur lequel les invités
prêtent leur vœu de croisade.
Les descriptions de ces banquets nous montrent
vraiment tout ce qui faisait l'époque féodale
et chevaleresque: on a un seigneur, entouré
de ses vassaux, qui les nourrit et respecte
le code chevaleresque à travers les tournois
et les entremets qui sont servis.
-Et pourtant, les banquets n'étaient pas
uniquement réservés aux nobles, bien au
contraire! Chez les pécores on festoyait
lors des grandes fêtes religieuses, pour
les baptêmes, les mariages, les enterrements...
Et on ne faisait pas gaffe à la dépense:
il y avait du pain blanc, du vin, de la viande
salée ou fraîche, et on pouvait même tuer
les animaux de travail s'il le fallait.
Bon, après, on était bien embêté quand
il fallait tirer soi-même la charrue.
-Pour conclure, l'alimentation médiévale
a évolué en terme de goûts, de proportions,
mais on garde longtemps cette tripartition
des céréales, de la viande, et du vin, le
reste consistant en des accompagnements puisque
les céréales étaient la principale source
de calories.
Depuis l'industrialisation, et surtout le
XXe siècle, on est sortis de cette organisation
mais c'est encore le cas dans de nombreux
pays, comme l'Asie du Sud-Est où la céréale
est le riz, qui compose l'essentiel de l'alimentation,
et le reste ne sert qu'à l'accompagner et
lui donner du goût.
Alors j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu
et vous a mis en appétit, pour ma part je
vous laisse: c'est l'heure du goûter!